steve's in rutland vermont hi steve how
are you
i'm not bad i'm a big fan of yours i've
been listening to it for years and thank
you ed you took my call like
how am i gonna get on your phone i'm
honored how can we help
okay i am a retired engineer
i've one kid graduated college and one's
still
in college both of them had college
funds that i fully funded
to pay for their degree so i'm pretty
much debt-free but here's my great
question
the question i have is i'm selling some
property in a ski resort town
and now i'm going to be going and
finding my retirement home
in florida because you have to pay a
state income tax and everybody knows the
common things should i take out a loan
or not i asked td bank and they said if
i had 99 000
of income shown they'll give me a 2.36
percent
and my financial institution was talking
about
2.65 percent i thought
question is it worth just writing a
check
buying the house that i want to retire
in same 68 maybe i'll last 15 years
to take a 15-year mortgage or a 30-year
mortgage
or just pay the check and
no mortgage okay i'm a little confused
or not i'm a little confused how long
did you say you've been listening to us
for almost a little over a year now over
here
okay all right cool well we appreciate
you being i love your discussions on the
phone
during the time have you ever heard us
say tell somebody to borrow money
uh you seem to be against it
[Laughter]
yeah that would be uh that would be true
and uh the reason
the reason is stability and peace
versus the risk that borrowing adds to
your equation and so
um i own a
vacation property as well i'll just put
it under that category
and it sure is a different thing to own
one of them
when there's no debt on it uh when they
call you up and go
oh there was a little storm down here
yeah hurricane and yeah yeah
yeah a paid off yeah i don't know so
you're going to sell those and you're
going to have the cash
to pay cash for your retirement house
and so i do have the cash
around here that would be known as a
no-brainer yeah go go go pay cash man
thanks for listening to us though for a
year but absolutely the only time we're
going to say to borrow money is when you
get your first mortgage
and then once you pay off that mortgage
we're going to really tell you don't go
back into debt
you know bottom line and the reason is
is that it gives you stability
particularly in your retirement years in
your wealth building in your life
to not have any money borrowed yes
y'all remember when this thing happened
called a pandemic
12 months ago and y'all were all scared
of losing your jobs and losing
everything and economic collapse you all
remember that
[Music]
that was 20 minutes ago people let me
tell you build your house out of bricks
not straw or sticks and that's called
debt free so that's how we're going to
advise you steve thank you for being in
our audience sir